SECRETARY WILL CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN ALVARADO. GIL. ARCHULETA.
ASHBY. ATKIN BECKER. BLAKE.
SPEER. BRADFORD CABALLERO.
CORTEZ. DALLEY. DODD DORADO.
EGGMAN. GLAZER. GONZALEZ GROVE.
OTERO. JONES. LAIRD LIMÓN.
MCGUIRE. MENGIBAR. MIN NEWMAN.
NGUYEN. NILO OCHOA. PADILLA.
PORTANTINO. ROTH RUBIO. SATO.
SKINNER. SMALLWOOD CUEVAS.
STERN. UMBERG. WAHAB. WIENER
WILK. A QUORUM IS PRESENT.
WOULD. THE MEMBERS. COLLEAGUES,
WE GOT TO GET BACK TO OUR DESKS
RIGHT NOW. WOULD THE MEMBERS AND
OUR GUESTS BE ON THE RAIL IN THE
GALLERY, PLEASE? RISE. WE WILL
BE LED IN PRAYER THIS MORNING BY
OUR CHAPLAIN, SISTER MICHELLE
GORMAN. AFTER WHICH, PLEASE
REMAIN STANDING FOR THE PLEDGE
OF ALLEGIANCE. THE. LET US
CENTER OURSELVES IN GOD'S
PRESENCE IN OUR DAILY EFFORTS TO
CREATE MORE PROSPEROUS
SOCIETIES. THE PROGRESSIVE ROCK
GROUP RUSH INVITES US TO LEAD
FROM OUR HEARTS AND THE ONES WHO
HOLD HIGH PLACES. THESE MUST BE
THE ONES TO START TO MOLD A NEW
REALITY CLOSER TO THE HEART OF
GOD, OF COMPASSION AND MERCY.
YOU DWELL IN THE DEEPEST
RECESSES OF OUR HEARTS WHERE YOU
KNOW OUR DREAMS AND HOPES FOR
POSITIVE CHANGE IN OUR WORLD. BE
WITH US AS WE WORK TO BRING
THOSE DREAMS TO LIFE BY OUR
ACTIONS FORGED WITH COURAGE AND
CREATIVITY, WITH PERSISTENCE AND
PATIENCE, UNTIL ALL THOSE
SEEKING A PLACE OF REFUGE AND
BELONGING CAN BE ASSURED OF
THEIR VALUE AND THEIR
CONTRIBUTION TO THE ONGOING
EVOLUTION OF OUR HUMAN FAMILY,
WE ASK THIS IN YOUR NAME. AMEN.
AMEN PLEASE JOIN ME IN THE
PLEDGE. I PLEDGE. TO THE
REPUBLIC FOR WHICH IT STANDS.
ONE NATION UNDER GOD,
INDIVISIBLE, WITH LIBERTY AND
JUSTICE FOR ALL. GOOD MORNING.
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE INTO
PRIVILEGES OF THE FLOOR.
SENATORS, WE HAVE FIVE
PRESENTATIONS TODAY. MY ASK OF
YOU IS WE TRANSITION INTO EACH
PRESENTATION SMOOTHLY AND THAT
IF YOU'RE PROVIDING A
PRESENTATION TO BE READY WHEN
IT'S YOUR TURN, WE'RE GOING TO
START WITH SENATOR LAIRD FROM
THE MAJORITY LEADER'S DESK.
SENATOR, ARE YOU PREPARED? I'M
PREPARED. THANK YOU. COLLEAGUES,
IF WE CAN SIT DOWN, OUR SENATOR
LAIRD HAS A PRESENTATION OF SOME
SPECIAL GUESTS. SENATOR, YOU MAY
PROCEED. THANK YOU VERY MUCH,
MADAM PRESIDENT. COLLEAGUES
TODAY WE CELEBRATE CANADA DAY
HERE AT THE CAPITOL. FOR OVER A
DECADE, THE CONSULATE GENERAL OF
CANADA IN SAN FRANCISCO HAS
HOSTED THEIR ANNUAL ADVOCACY DAY
TO MEET WITH LEGISLATORS, POLICY
MAKERS AND FRIENDS OF CANADA IN
SACRAMENTO TO CELEBRATE THE
CANADA, CALIFORNIA RELATIONSHIP.
THIS IS A WELCOME I OPPORTUNITY
TO HIGHLIGHT THE BOND WE HAVE. I
SHOULD NOTE THAT THE VERY FIRST
SENATE TRIP AFTER THE PANDEMIC
WAS TO VANCOUVER, AND NOT ONLY
DID THE CONSULATE GENERAL HELP
WITH ALL THE MEETINGS AND THE
VISITS, HE CAME AND ACCOMPANIED
THE SENATE DELEGATION AT THAT
TIME, AND HE'S WORKING ON A
SIMILAR TRIP THIS SUMMER FOR
INTERESTED SENATORS TO OTTAWA,
MONTREAL AND QUEBEC, WHICH I
HOPE MANY OF YOU WERE AVAIL
YOURSELVES OF. WE HAVE A
TRILLION IN TRADE THAT FLOWS
BETWEEN OUR BORDERS, AND IT IS A
VERY STRONG RELATIONSHIP. SO TO
CELEBRATE THE RELATIONSHIP AND
CANADA DAY, WE WELCOME TO OUR
SENATE CHAMBER TODAY, THE CONSUL
GENERAL OF CANADA IN SAN
FRANCISCO. AND SILICON VALLEY,
MR. RANA SARKAR, TOGETHER WITH
MEMBERS OF HIS TEAM. HE WAS
PERSONALLY PICKED BY PRIME
MINISTER JUSTIN TRUDEAU TO GROW
THE CALIFORNIA, CANADA
RELATIONSHIP. THE DEEP AND
HISTORIC PARTNERSHIP IS A
WELLSPRING OF STRENGTH TO US
ALL. I URGE YOU ALL TO GIVE A
RAUCOUS SENATE WELCOME TO THE
COUNCIL GENERAL OF CANADA AND
HIS TEAM. WELCOME COUNSEL
GENERAL, AND WELCOME TO YOUR
TEAM. WE'RE GOING TO TAKE A
QUICK PHOTO WITH THE SENATOR.
AND THEN IF YOU'RE INTERESTED IN
THE GROUP PHOTO, BE PREPARED.
THAT'S COMING NEXT. SO FIRST
WITH THE SENATOR.
ALL RIGHT. THIS IS YOUR MOMENT,
COLLEAGUES, IF YOU WISH TO BE IN
THE PHOTO, THE GROUP PHOTO
.
SMOOTH TRANSITION. COLLEAGUES,
LET'S GET READY FOR THIS PHOTO
.
ALL RIGHT. COLLEAGUES, MEMBERS.
WITHOUT OBJECTION, WE WILL TAKE
UP THE FOLLOWING RESOLUTIONS.
OUT OF ORDER. SR 85, SCR 129,
AND SCR 130. AFTER ADOPTION OF
EACH RESOLUTION, WE WILL RETURN
TO PRIVILEGES OF THE FLOOR FOR
THE AUTHOR TO INTRODUCE THEIR
GUESTS. WE'RE GOING TO BE
PLAYING A LITTLE BIT OF PING
PONG BACK AND FORTH AFTER EACH
RESOLUTION. WE WILL BEGIN WITH
THE MAJORITY LEADER, SENATOR
GONZALEZ, FROM HER DESK ON FILE
ITEM 43 SR 85. SECRETARY, PLEASE
READ SENATE RESOLUTION 85 BY
SENATOR GONZALEZ RELATIVE TO
CAMBODIAN GENOCIDE MEMORIAL WEEK
. GOOD. GOOD AFTERNOON, MAJORITY
LEADER. GIVE ME A SECOND HERE.
IF WE CAN GET OUR COLLEAGUES TO
PLEASE LOWER OUR VOICES. IN
FACT, IF YOU HAVE A
CONVERSATION, TAKE IT OFF THE
FLOOR. OUR MAJORITY LEADER IS
SPEAKING RIGHT NOW. SENATOR, YOU
MAY PROCEED. THANK YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON, MADAM PRESIDENT AND
COLLEAGUES. I RISE TODAY TO
PRESENT SR 85, WHICH WILL
RECOGNIZE THE WEEK OF APRIL 17TH
THROUGH THE 23RD AS CAMBODIAN
GENOCIDE MEMORIAL WEEK BETWEEN
APRIL 17TH, 1975 AND JANUARY
1979, THE KHMER ROUGE, UNDER THE
LEADERSHIP OF POL POT, COMMITTED
ACTS OF GENOCIDE AND CRIMES
AGAINST HUMANITY AGAINST THE
CAMBODIAN PEOPLE. THIS GENOCIDE
RESULTED IN THE DEATHS OF MORE
THAN 1.7 MILLION CAMBODIANS,
NEARLY A QUARTER OF THIS
COUNTRY'S POPULATION AT THE
TIME. THE KHMER ROUGE REGIME
ALSO SOUGHT TO ELIMINATE ALL
ASPECTS OF CAMBODIAN CULTURE BY
SYSTEMATICALLY KILLING THOSE
WITH EDUCATION, THÀNH,
SEPARATING FAMILIES AND
DESTROYING INSTITUTIONS SUCH AS
BUDDHIST TEMPLES, SCHOOLS,
LIBRARIES, DANCE, AND MUSIC.
TODAY CALIFORNIA IS HOME TO THE
LARGEST POPULATION OF CAMBODIAN
AMERICANS AND THE CITY OF LONG
BEACH IN MY DISTRICT IS HOME TO
THE LARGEST COMMUNITY OF
CAMBODIANS OUTSIDE OF SOUTHEAST
ASIA, TO WHICH I AM VERY PROUD.
SR 85 HONORS THOSE LIVES LOST
DURING THE CAMBODIAN GENOCIDE,
AND MARKS THIS WEEK AS A
MEMORIAL WEEK FOR THE CAMBODIAN
COMMUNITY IN RECOGNITION OF THE
GENOCIDE MEMORIAL WEEK. ON YOUR
DESKS ARE SILK ANIMAL ORNAMENTS
LOVINGLY HANDMADE BY CAMBODIAN
COMMUNITY MEMBERS IN MY
DISTRICT. THANK YOU. AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. SENATOR MINH, YOU'RE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU, MADAM
PRESIDENT. FELLOW SENATORS, ON
BEHALF OF THE ASIAN AMERICAN AND
PACIFIC ISLANDER LEGISLATIVE
CAUCUS, I RISE IN SUPPORT OF SR
85 AND WANT TO THANK MY
COLLEAGUE FROM LONG BEACH FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD. AS SHE
NOTED, THIS MEMORIAL WEEK
OBSERVED FROM APRIL 17TH TO
APRIL 23RD, HONORS THE MEMORY OF
MORE THAN 2 MILLION CAMBODIANS
WHO LOST THEIR LIVES BETWEEN THE
YEARS 1975 AND 1979. DURING THIS
GENOCIDE, AND PRIVATE PROPERTY,
CURRENCY, RELIGIOUS PRACTICES,
TRADITIONAL CULTURE WERE
ERADICATED. MILLIONS OF
CAMBODIANS WERE SENT TO LABOR
CAMPS, AS WELL AS MASS
EXECUTIONS OF JOURNALISTS,
ARTISTS, AND STUDENTS, AND THE
HORRORS OF THE KHMER ROUGE
CONTINUE TO PERVADE THE LIVES OF
CAMBODIANS AND HAS LEFT
GENERATIONS OF CAMBODIANS HERE
AND ABROAD WITH DEEP SEATED
TRAUMA. I WANT TO THANK MY
COLLEAGUE FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD, BECAUSE IT'S ONLY WITH
ACKNOWLEDGING THAT THIS HORRIBLE
EVENT THAT WE CAN HELP TO
CONTINUE EDUCATING FOLKS, TO TRY
TO PREVENT THIS TYPE OF ACTION
FROM EVER HAPPENING AGAIN. SO I
ASK THAT YOU JOIN ME IN
SUPPORTING SR 85. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. SENATOR, DO WE HAVE
ANY SENATOR STERN, YOU'RE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU, MADAM
PRESIDENT. AS, AS A MEMBER OF
THE JEWISH CAUCUS WHO ALSO
CHAIRS THE STATE COUNCIL ON
HOLOCAUST AND GENOCIDE
EDUCATION, I WANT TO STAND IN
FAVOR OF THIS RESOLUTION AND
REALLY RECOGNIZE THIS SHARED
DESTINY THAT SURVIVORS HAVE OF
GENOCIDES IN THIS STATE. CHENNY
LAW IS A WOMAN FROM THE BAY AREA
WHO SURVIVED THE KILLING FIELDS.
AS A LITTLE GIRL, I WOULD
RECOMMEND TO EVERYONE IN THE
BOOK SHORT HAIRED GIRL. IF YOU
HAVE NOT YET READ IT, IT IS A
HARROWING STORY, BUT ULTIMATELY
NOW AN ENTREPRENEUR, A BUSINESS
OWNER, AND A AND A LEADER, BUT
HAD NEVER TALKED ABOUT HER
EXPERIENCES AND NOW GOES AROUND
WITH SURVIVORS OF THE HOLOCAUST
WITH SURVIVORS OF THOSE KILLING
FIELDS TO, TO HIGH SCHOOLS
AROUND THE BAY AREA AND AROUND
THE STATE. AND NOW THEY'RE
TRAINING TEACHERS IN CALIFORNIA
HOW TO TEACH THROUGH THIS
MATERIAL SO THAT IT DOESN'T
BECOME SOME VESTIGE OF HISTORY
OR A MOVIE YOU ONCE SAW, OR SOME
KIND OF EXOTIC OR FOREIGN TALE.
BUT IT'S REAL. AND EVERY, EVERY
GOVERNMENT ON EARTH IS
SUSCEPTIBLE TO THIS. AND PEOPLE,
OUR NEIGHBORS HAVE GONE THROUGH
IT. SO THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD. AND IN
THAT SPIRIT OF SOLIDARITY, I ASK
FOR YOUR VOTE. THANK YOU. ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE?
MAJORITY LEADER SENATOR
GONZALEZ, YOU MAY CLOSE. I THANK
MY GOOD COLLEAGUES FROM LOS
ANGELES AND IRVINE, AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ELLEN. AYE, I'LL RODA-GIL
AYE. ARCHULETA. AYE. ASHBY. AYE
AYE. ATKINS. AYE. BECKER. AYE
BLAKE. SPEER. AYE. BRADFORD AYE.
CABALLERO. AYE. CORTEZ AYE.
DALLY. AYE. DODD AYE. DURAZZO.
AYE. EGGMAN AYE. GLAZER. AYE.
GONZALEZ AYE. GROVE HURTADO.
JONES. AYE. LAIRD. AYE. LIMÓN
AYE. MCGUIRE AYE. MENGIBAR. AYE.
MIN. I NEWMAN. AYE. NGUYEN AYE.
NILO. AYE. OKOBO. AYE PADILLA.
AYE. PORTANTINO AYE. ROTH AYE.
RUBIO AYE. SATO AYE. SKINNER
AYE. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS AYE.
STERN. AYE UMBERG. AYE. WAHAB
AYE. WIENER AYE. WILK AYE.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. GROVE AYE.
HURTADO AYES 39. NO. ZERO. THE
RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED. MAJORITY
LEADER, ARE YOU PREPARED FOR
YOUR PRESENTATION? PLEASE
PROCEED. THANK YOU, MADAM
PRESIDENT AND MEMBERS, TO MARK
CAMBODIAN GENOCIDE MEMORIAL
WEEK. I AM HONORED TO BE JOINED
BY SEVERAL COMMUNITY LEADERS
FROM LONG BEACH, THE HOME, OF
COURSE, AS I ALWAYS MENTIONED,
OF THE LARGEST CAMBODIAN
COMMUNITY, I AM JOINED TODAY BY
LÀ DEAN CHAN, PROC LEE, DOCTOR
SARAH LIM, RITHY HAN, T I VÌ
GALANO. FIRST, I'LL START WITH
MR. DEAN CHAN WAS BORN IN THE
KHAO-I-DANG REFUGEE CAMP IN
THAILAND. HIS FAMILY SETTLED IN
LONG BEACH IN THE EARLY 1980S
AND HAS SINCE THEN CALLED LONG
BEACH HOME. CURRENTLY, HE SERVES
AS THE PROGRAM MANAGER AT SAINT
MARY MEDICAL CENTER AND FAMILIES
IN GOOD HEALTH. WITH OVER 20
YEARS OF EXPERIENCE IN COMMUNITY
ORGANIZING AND MENTORING MANY,
MANY YOUTH, MR. PROC LEE IS AN
INTERNATIONALLY RENOWNED,
CRITICALLY ACCLAIMED, AWARD
WINNING ARTIST. HE'S THE FOUNDER
OF CAMBODIA TOWN FILM FESTIVAL
AND HIS DEBUT ALBUM IS THE FIRST
NUMBER ONE RAP ALBUM IN CAMBODIA
, AND NEWSWEEK PROCLAIMED HIM AS
THE FIRST CAMBODIAN RAP STAR.
THROUGH MASTERFUL LYRICS, HIS
MUSIC NOT ONLY ENTERTAINS BUT
ALSO EDUCATES. HIS LYRICS HAVE
BEEN PUBLISHED BY MULTIPLE
SOURCES AND ARE CURRENTLY BEING
USED IN SOUTHEAST ASIAN STUDIES.
DOCTOR SARAH LIM ASSIST THE
ORANGE COUNTY DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION WITH THE CAMBODIAN
AMERICAN STUDIES MODEL
CURRICULUM, TO WHICH SHE HELPED
ME PASS JUST LAST YEAR. SHE
SERVES ON THE EXECUTIVE BOARD OF
TRUSTEES FOR SAINT MARY MEDICAL
CENTER FOUNDATION IN LONG BEACH,
AND SHE PERSONALLY SURVIVED THE
CAMBODIAN GENOCIDE WITH HER
MOTHER, BUT UNFORTUNATELY LOST
HER FATHER AND THREE BROTHERS TO
THE KHMER ROUGE. SINCE THE KHMER
ROUGE TARGETED THE EDUCATED
CLASS, DOCTOR PO LIM HAS TAKEN
IT UPON HERSELF TO RESTORE THE
EDUCATIONAL VALUES OF THE
COMMUNITY AND BY CONTINUING HER
EDUCATION UNTIL SHE ACHIEVED A
DOCTORATE IN EDUCATIONAL
LEADERSHIP FROM CAL STATE LONG
BEACH IN 2018. MR. CHAN IS AN
ORGANIZER IN THE CAMBODIAN
COMMUNITY OF LONG BEACH AND A
SENIOR ADVOCATE AT THE LEGAL
NONPROFIT ORGANIZATION
DISABILITY RIGHTS CALIFORNIA.
WHEN HE IS NOT SALSA DANCING OR
CARRYING KARAOKE, SINGING, YOU
WILL FIND HIM IN THE COMMUNITY
VOLUNTEERING HIS FREE TIME. FOR
THE PAST SIX YEARS, RITHY HAS
BEEN PARTNERING WITH LOCAL
BUSINESSES IN THE COMMUNITY TO
COLLECT TOYS TO BE DISTRIBUTED,
AND HE ALSO ORGANIZES THE KUMAI
COMMUNITY DAY EVENTS WITH THE
KUMAI ALUMNI ASSOCIATION AND
LASTLY, MR. TV. MISS TV GALANO
WAS A PUBLIC SERVANT FOR 42
YEARS, SERVING IN THE LOS
ANGELES COUNTY CHILD SUPPORT
SERVICES DEPARTMENT. HER
COMMUNITY SERVICE INCLUDES
SERVING ON THE BOARD OF UNITED
KAMEHAMEHA ACTION COALITION AND
CAMBODIAN AMERICAN CULTURAL
CENTER, AND HAS SERVED ON THE
ADVISORY BOARD FOR THE
COORDINATING COUNCIL FOR THE
CAMBODIAN CULTURE AND ART
ASSOCIATION. AND IN 2017, SHE
WAS ACTUALLY THE GRAND MARSHAL
FOR THE MARTIN LUTHER KING
JUNIOR PARADE IN LONG BEACH,
AMONG MANY, MANY OTHER ACCOLADES
. PLEASE JOIN ME MEMBERS IN
WELCOMING THESE CAMBODIAN
COMMUNITY LEADERS AND THANK THEM
FOR THEIR COMMITMENT TO THE
CALIFORNIA STATE SENATE AND TO
OUR STATE. THANK YOU. WELCOME.
WE'LL TAKE THE FIRST PHOTO WITH
THE MAJORITY LEADER, AND THEN
I'LL INVITE ANY OTHER MEMBERS TO
STEP ON IN FOR THE GROUP PHOTO.
IF ANY MEMBER WISHES TO
PARTICIPATE IN THIS GROUP PHOTO,
NOW IS YOUR CHANCE. WHAT IS HE
DOING? NO, NO. FORGET HIM
.
ALL RIGHT. COLLEAGUES WE'RE BACK
TO BUSINESS. WE'RE MOVING
TOWARDS, FILE ITEM 40 ON SCR
129. SECRETARY, PLEASE READ.
SENATOR. HOLD ON. SORRY.
SECRETARY. SENATOR PADILLA, ARE
YOU PREPARED? I AM, THANK YOU.
SECRETARY. PLEASE READ SENATE
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION 129 BY
SENATOR PADILLA RELATIVE TO
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC SAFETY,
TELECOMMUNICATIONS WEEK. THANK
YOU, MADAM PRESIDENT. AND
MEMBERS, I RISE TO PRESENT SCR
129, WHICH DECLARES THE WEEK OF
APRIL 14TH THROUGH APRIL 20TH AS
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC SAFETY
TELECOMMUNICATIONS WEEK.
CALIFORNIA HAS OVER 8000 PUBLIC
SAFETY DISPATCHERS, INCLUDING
LAW ENFORCEMENT, FIRE, EMS AND
OTHER PUBLIC SAFETY OPERATIONS.
THESE DISPATCHERS ANSWER OVER 27
MILLION 911 CALLS ANNUALLY. THIS
WEEK CELEBRATED ANNUALLY HONORS
THE THOUSANDS OF MEN AND WOMEN
RESPOND TO EMERGENCY CALLS,
DISPATCH EMERGENCY RESPONDERS
AND EQUIPMENT, AND RENDER LIFE
SAVING ASSISTANCE TO
CALIFORNIANS 24 HOURS A DAY. 365
DAYS A YEAR. PUBLIC SAFETY
TELECOMMUNICATORS WEEK IS
CELEBRATED NATIONALLY, BUT IT
GOT STARTED HERE IN CALIFORNIA
WHEN, IN 1981, PATRICIA ANDERSON
OF THE CONTRA COSTA COUNTY
SHERIFF'S OFFICE FIRST PROMOTED
THIS IDEA TO ALL OF OUR
DISPATCHERS AND SYSTEM
PROFESSIONALS. WE THANK YOU FOR
ALL THE SACRIFICES YOU MAKE TO
CREATE A BETTER AND SAFER WORLD
FOR ALL OF US AND THE PUBLIC.
MADAM PRESIDENT AND COLLEAGUES,
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU. DO WE HAVE ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM? SEEING NONE, MEMBERS. THIS
ITEM IS ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS
ROLL CALL. DO WE HAVE ANY
OBJECTION? AND UTILIZING THE
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL, SEEING NONE
. AYES 39. NO ZERO. THE
RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED. SENATOR
PADILLA, ARE YOU PREPARED FOR
YOUR PRESENTATION? I AM, PLEASE
PROCEED. THANK YOU, MADAM
PRESIDENT. I'M JOINED AND
HONORED TO BE JOINED TODAY BY A
FEW AMAZING PROFESSIONALS FROM
PUBLIC SAFETY TELECOMS. MANDY
REYNOLDS, PRESIDENT OF CAL,
NINA, THE CALIFORNIA CHAPTER OF
THE NATIONAL EMERGENCY NUMBERS
ASSOCIATION. TRISTAN SCRIBER,
PRESIDENT OF NORCAL APCO, THE
ASSOCIATION OF PUBLIC SAFETY
COMMUNICATIONS OFFICIALS, AND
TERRY NELSON, PRESIDENT OF THE
SO-CALLED APCO CPRA CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC SAFETY RADIO ASSOCIATION.
MADAM PRESIDENT AND COLLEAGUES,
PLEASE MAKE THEM WELCOME.
WELCOME TO THE CALIFORNIA STATE
SENATE
.
SENATORS, NOW IS THEIR TIME. IF
YOU WISH TO PARTICIPATE IN THE
GROUP PHOTO
.
WE'RE MOVING FORWARD NOW ON FILE
ITEM 41. SCR 130. SENATOR
NEWMAN, ARE YOU PREPARED FROM
THE MAJORITY LEADER'S DESK?
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ SENATE
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION 130 BY
SENATOR NEWMAN, RELATIVE TO CASA
APPRECIATION DAY. THANK YOU,
MADAM PRESIDENT. IT'S MY GREAT
PRIVILEGE TO PRESENT SCR 130,
WHICH WILL COMMEMORATE APRIL
18TH, 2024, AS CASA APPRECIATION
DAY IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
A COURT APPOINTED SPECIAL
ADVOCATES, OR CASA VOLUNTEERS,
OR CASAS, AS THEY ARE CALLED,
ACT AS CHAMPIONS FOR THE RIGHTS
AND WELL-BEING OF CHILDREN
WITHIN THE FOSTER SYSTEM. THESE
GENEROUS AND CARING ADVOCATES
PLAY A VERY IMPORTANT ROLE FOR
CHILDREN IN FOSTER CARE. AS THEY
NAVIGATE THE COMPLEX AND
SOMETIMES OVERWHELMING JUVENILE
COURT SYSTEM. CALIFORNIA'S
FOSTER CARE SYSTEM CURRENTLY
SUPPORTS OVER 70,000 CHILDREN,
MANY OF WHOM HAVE EXPERIENCED
ABUSE, NEGLECT OR ABANDONMENT.
CASAS MAY START AS EVERYDAY
PEOPLE WHO ANSWER THE CALL TO
ASSIST A CHILD IN FOSTER CARE,
BUT ONCE TRAINED AND APPOINTED
BY JUDGES, THEY SERVE AS
ADVOCATES TO ENSURE THAT IN THE
MIDST OF THE LABYRINTHINE AND
OFTEN CHAOTIC WORLD OF THE
FOSTER SYSTEM, THE VOICES AND
UNIQUE PERSPECTIVES OF THE
CHILDREN THEMSELVES WILL BE
HEARD AND CONSIDERED IN 2022,
MORE THAN 8600 DEDICATED COST OF
VOLUNTEERS SERVED MORE THAN
12,000 CALIFORNIA FOSTER
CHILDREN, DONATING A CUMULATIVE
TOTAL OF OVER 400,000 HOURS OF
THEIR COLLECTIVE TIME. THESE
DEDICATED INDIVIDUALS UNDERGO
EXTENSIVE TRAINING TO UNDERSTAND
THE CHILD WELFARE SYSTEM AND
COURT PROCEDURES, AND THE
SPECIFIC NEEDS OF YOUNG PEOPLE
IN FOSTER CARE. THEY CULTIVATE
RELATIONSHIPS WITH THEIR FOSTER
CHILDREN, BECOMING FAMILIAR WITH
THEIR FAMILIES AND CAREGIVERS,
RECOGNIZE THEIR CIRCUMSTANCES,
AND SERVING AS POWERFUL
ADVOCATES FOR THE CHILDREN'S
BEST INTERESTS. A CASA IS OFTEN
THE ONLY CONSISTENT SUPPORT OF
ADULT IN A FOSTER CHILD'S LIFE,
PROVIDING CONSTANCY AND
ENCOURAGEMENT SIMPLY BY
LISTENING. OFFERING
ENCOURAGEMENT AND GUIDANCE, AND
PROVIDING VITAL REASSURANCE.
THEY WORK COMPASSIONATELY AND
RELENTLESSLY AT ENSURING THAT
ALL CHILDREN CAN HAVE SAFE,
LOVING HOMES AND A SYSTEM THAT
SAFEGUARDS THEIR NEEDS. MY WIFE
AND I BOTH HAD THE PRIVILEGE OF
SERVING AS CASAS, AND HAVE SEEN
THE POWER OF THIS UNIQUE BRAND
OF ADVOCACY FIRSTHAND. OUR
EXPERIENCES AS CASA VOLUNTEERS
GAVE US A BETTER UNDERSTANDING
OF THE CHALLENGES AND
COMPLEXITIES FOSTER CHILDREN
FACE, AND HOW CRITICAL IT IS TO
HAVE AN ADULT TO ADVISE THEM.
GUIDE THEM, AND CHAMPION THEIR
RIGHTS. I'M VERY CERTAIN THAT
I'M A BETTER LEGISLATOR AS WELL
AS A BETTER PERSON. AS A RESULT
OF THAT EXPERIENCE, EVEN IF MY
WIFE WAS DEFINITELY A BETTER
CASA THAN I WAS. COLLEAGUES,
CASA VOLUNTEERS, AND THE COST OF
PROGRAMS ACROSS THE STATE WHO
RECRUIT AND SUPPORT THEM
EXEMPLIFY THE IDEAL OF THE GOOD
SAMARITAN AND WHAT IT MEANS TO
ASSIST AND ELEVATE SOME OF THE
MOST VULNERABLE MEMBERS OF OUR
SOCIETY. PLEASE JOIN ME IN
RECOGNIZING THE INVALUABLE
CONTRIBUTIONS OF COURT APPOINTED
SPECIAL ADVOCATES BY DESIGNATING
APRIL 18, 2024, AS CASA
APPRECIATION DAY. I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR VOTE, SENATOR
ASHBY, YOU'RE RECOGNIZED. THANK
YOU, MADAM PRESIDENT. I WANT TO
THANK THE SENATOR FROM FULLERTON
FOR BRINGING FORWARD THIS TODAY.
AND YOU KNOW, OFTEN WHEN WE TALK
ABOUT THESE ISSUES, I THINK
ABOUT MY DAD, WHO WAS THE HEAD
OF FOSTER CARE FOR STATE OF
CALIFORNIA FOR SO MANY YEARS.
AND HE USED TO SAY THIS OFTEN,
THE ONLY THING THAT A CHILD
NEEDS TO CHANGE THEIR LIFE IS
ONE CARING ADULT. AND FOR THOSE
OF US WHO HAVE WORKED IN THIS
SYSTEM FOR A LONG TIME OR HAVE
BEEN IN COURTS AND WORKED
ALONGSIDE CASA VOLUNTEERS, WE
KNOW THAT VERY OFTEN THAT CARING
ADULT FOR ONE YOUNG FOSTER YOUTH
WAS A MEMBER OF THE CASA TEAM.
SOMEBODY WHO VOLUNTEERED TO WALK
THROUGH THE VERY DIFFICULT PARTS
OF THE COURT SYSTEM WITH THIS
YOUNG PERSON. SO I WANTED TO
RISE TODAY IN SUPPORT OF THE
RESOLUTION AND THANK THE SENATOR
FROM FULLERTON, SENATOR WAHAB,
YOU'RE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU. I
JUST WANT TO SAY I AGAIN,
APPRECIATE MY COLLEAGUE FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD. IT'S
INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT AS A PERSON
WHO GREW UP IN THE FOSTER CARE
SYSTEM, GENUINELY, THERE'S NOT
ENOUGH ADVOCATES FOR FOLKS. AND
I THINK CASA IN PARTICULAR
ALLOWS FOR YOUTH TO HAVE A
MENTOR. AND REGARDLESS OF THEIR
PLACEMENT, THAT MENTOR USUALLY
STICKS WITH THEM AS MUCH AS
POSSIBLE. AND, YOU KNOW, CASA IN
PARTICULAR ALLOWS FOR THE CASA
INDIVIDUAL TO BE ABLE TO TELL
THE YOUTH, YOU KNOW, LIKE HERE
ARE YOUR OPPORTUNITIES. IT'S AN
EXTRA, SUPPORT SYSTEM THAT IS
VERY MUCH NEEDED, SHOULD BE WELL
FUNDED AND IT SHOULD MOVE
FORWARD AND EXPAND. AND I THINK
THAT WE DON'T OFTEN REALIZE HOW
OFTEN FOSTER YOUTH REALLY DO
FALL THROUGH THE CRACKS. IT IS A
BROKEN SYSTEM. IT HAS BEEN
BROKEN FOR DECADES. IT IS A
FAILURE ON THE GOVERNMENT'S
PART, AND I'M PERSONALLY
SPEAKING FROM THIS POINT, AND
IT'S REALLY, REALLY SAD TO SEE
THE STATISTICS ABOUT FOSTER
YOUTH ON A GOVERNMENT BACKED
PROGRAM WHERE THE YOUTH ARE IN
THIS SYSTEM AT NO FAULT OF THEIR
OWN. THEY ARE YOUTH AND WE
DESERVE TO GIVE THEM EVERY
SINGLE OPPORTUNITY THAT THEY CAN
HAVE, INCLUDING ADDITIONAL.
PEOPLE THAT CAN JUST KEEP EYES
ON THEM AND TAKE CARE OF THEM
AND SEE IF THEY CAN HELP IN ANY
WAY THEY CAN. SO I REALLY DO
APPRECIATE THE, RESOLUTION. AND
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE AS
WELL. SENATOR GROVE, YOU'RE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU, MADAM
PRESIDENT. I TOO, RISE IN
SUPPORT OF SCR 130, I GOT
INVOLVED IN CASA PROBABLY TEN
YEARS AGO BECAUSE I WENT TO A
CASA EVENT THAT WE HAVE IN OUR
DISTRICT WHERE YOU CAN TAKE A
PERSON, A CHILD'S NAME OFF THE
WALL, AND YOU CAN BUY A GIFT
THAT'S LISTED SO THEY ACTUALLY
GET A REAL GIFT. IT WAS A
COTTAGE HOUSE FOR CASA, AND,
THIS GIRL COMES IN AND SHE'S
PULLING ALL THESE THINGS OFF THE
WALL. AND AGAIN, LOOKING AT THIS
PERSON, I THOUGHT, THERE'S NO
WAY SHE HAS THE MONEY TO BUY ALL
THOSE GIFTS. AND SO I GOT A
LITTLE NERVOUS. AND THE CASA
PEOPLE WERE NERVOUS, TOO. AND WE
WALKED OVER AND WE SAID HI, AND
WE INTRODUCED OURSELVES, AND SHE
SAID, WE GOT TO KNOW HER. AND
SHE'S A WAITRESS AT A RESTAURANT
IN TOWN, AND SHE WAS TELLING US
THAT SHE SAVES ALL OF HER TIPS.
SHE LIVES VERY CHEAPLY, AND SHE
SAVES ALL OF HER TIPS BECAUSE
WHEN SHE WAS IN FOSTER YOUTH,
THIS WAS THE ONLY GIFT SHE EVER
GOT. AND WHEN SHE WAS IN FOSTER
CARE, SHE WAS. THIS WAS THE ONLY
GIFT SHE EVER GOT. AND SO SARAH
AND I BECAME QUICK FRIENDS. WE
WORKED ON LEGISLATION IN THE
ASSEMBLY BEFORE, AND I HAVE TO
TELL YOU THIS, YOU KNOW, I'VE
NEVER LIKE THE MY FORMER
COLLEAGUE, MY COLLEAGUE THAT
JUST SPOKE, SHE WAS IN THE
FOSTER CARE SYSTEM. SO NOBODY
CAN EXPERIENCE HER LIVED
EXPERIENCE IS DIFFERENT THAN ALL
OF US. BUT I REMEMBER TAKING
SARAH TO A ROTARY CLUB, AND WE
WERE TRYING TO GET HER INVOLVED
IN THE COMMUNITY SO THAT SHE
COULD SHARE HER STORY. AND THIS
LADY COMES UP TO HER AND SHE
GOES, DO YOU REMEMBER ME? SARAH
STARTS CRYING AND SHE SAID, THE
CODE WORD WAS FLUBBER. THE CODE
WORD WAS FLUBBER. AND THEN I
HAVE THESE TWO GROWN WOMEN JUST
CRYING IN FRONT OF ME. SARAH WAS
PLACED IN A FOSTER FAMILY HOUSE
WHERE ABUSE WAS TAKING PLACE,
AND WHEN THEY CHECKED ON HER,
THE CASA CHECKED ON HER IN
PERSON. IT WAS LIKE A BED OF
ROSES AND COOKIES AND CREAM.
RIGHT? BUT WHEN THIS FOSTER,
WHEN THE CASA WOULD LEAVE, THERE
WOULD BE DETRIMENTAL TREATMENT
TO SARAH. AND SO SHE WALKED IN
AND SHE GOES, HEY, ARE YOU
WATCHING TV? AND SHE GOES, WE
WATCHED FLUBBER AND THE MOM, THE
FOSTER MOM LOOKED AT HER LIKE WE
DIDN'T WATCH FLUBBER. AND
EVERYBODY GOT IT. AND THEY GOT
SARAH OUT OF THERE. AND WHEN
THEY GOT SARAH OUT OF THERE, HER
LITTLE BROTHER WAS IN A CAGE IN
THE GARAGE WHEN THEY WENT IN,
AND THAT. SO I AGREE WITH MY
COLLEAGUE. WE HAVE A LOT OF WORK
TO DO ON THE FOSTER CARE SYSTEM.
THESE INDIVIDUALS ARE WARDS OF
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. IT IS
NOT THEIR FAULT THEY ARE IN THIS
SITUATION. IT'S BECAUSE OF
SOMETHING THEIR PARENTS HAVE
DONE TO PUT THEM IN THIS
SITUATION. I WOULD LOVE TO SEE
LEGISLATION ON CATEGORICAL
SPENDING. SO IF YOU'RE A FOSTER
CARE PERSON, YOU'RE NOT GOING TO
GET RICH OFF THIS KID. AND
THEY'RE NOT GOING TO EMANCIPATE
WITH A WITH A PILLOWCASE FULL OF
STUFF. THEY SHOULD HAVE MONEY IN
A BANK ACCOUNT FOR A CAR. THEY
SHOULD HAVE MONEY IN A BANK
ACCOUNT FOR EDUCATION, BECAUSE
SOME OF THESE PEOPLE GET
THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS A MONTH,
AND IT DOESN'T COST THOUSANDS OF
DOLLARS A MONTH TO FEED AND
HOUSE A CHILD. SO I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE AND THINK
THAT THERE ARE A LOT MORE WORK
TO DO ON THIS. AND JUST ON A
SIDE NOTE, BECAUSE I'M STILL
REALLY, REALLY, FRANKLY UPSET
ABOUT TUESDAY OR WEDNESDAY OR
WHENEVER THAT TOOK PLACE BECAUSE
MY DAYS ARE RUNNING TOGETHER, WE
ABANDONED OUR FOSTER CARE,
SPECIFICALLY OUR 16 AND 17 YEAR
OLDS IN A COMMITTEE. THE OTHER
DAY THAT SAYS, SENATOR, IF YOU
COULD STICK TO THE MERIT OF THIS
RESOLUTION, PLEASE. ABSOLUTELY.
THE 16 AND 17 YEAR OLDS IN THE
FOSTER CARE SYSTEM ARE STILL
GOING TO BE ON A STREET WITH A
MISDEMEANOR, RESPECTFULLY ASKED
FOR AN AYE VOTE, SENATOR. ALSO
YOU'RE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU, I
BECAME AWARE OF CASA THROUGH A
VISIT I DID TO CHILDREN'S COURT
IN LOS ANGELES, AND THEN BECAME
INTRODUCED TO THE ORGANIZATION
AND THEN IN OUR BUDGET
SUBCOMMITTEE, WORKED WITH
SENATOR NEWMAN ON GETTING THE
FUNDING. BUT THE FUNDING WAS
JUST TO MAINTAIN THE STRUCTURE,
THE INFRASTRUCTURE NEEDED FOR
VOLUNTEERS TO BE ABLE TO SUBMIT
THEIR PUT IN THEIR TIME, THE,
THE CASA VOLUNTEERS PUT IN
EXTRAORDINARY NUMBER OF HOURS TO
BE TRAINED TO SPEND WITH THE
YOUTH AND I'VE JUST BEEN SO
IMPRESSED AS JUST AN
EXTRAORDINARY ORGANIZATION. AND
I WANT TO THANK ALL OF THE CASA
VOLUNTEERS AND SENATOR NEWMAN
FOR RAISING THE ISSUE. THANK
YOU. SEN. NEWMAN, WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE? YES. SO THANK YOU TO
ALL OF MY COLLEAGUES FOR YOUR
WORDS FROM DIFFERENT
PERSPECTIVES, BUT ALL MAKING
ESSENTIALLY THE SAME POINT THAT
THE FOSTER CARE SYSTEM IS
CHALLENGED. BUT THE SILVER
LINING WITHIN THAT SYSTEM ARE
THE WONDERFUL VOLUNTEERS FROM
CASA AND THE FOLKS WHO SUPPORT
THEM, WE SHOULD BE GRATEFUL. WE
SHOULD SUPPORT THEIR EFFORTS AND
I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE,
VOTE ON THIS RESOLUTION TODAY.
THANK YOU SO MUCH, COLLEAGUES.
THIS ITEM IS ALSO ELIGIBLE FOR
UNANIMOUS ROLLCALL. ANY
OBJECTION TO UTILIZING THE
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL? SEEING
NONE, AYES 39. NO. ZERO. THIS
RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED. THANK
YOU. SENATOR, WE HAVE ONE FINAL
PRESENTATION. JUST KIDDING.
INTRODUCTIONS. SENATOR NEWMAN,
YOU MAY PROCEED WITH YOUR
PRESENTATION. THANK YOU. AND
WITH US THIS MORNING TO
CELEBRATE COST APPRECIATION DAY
ARE A FEW OF THE WONDERFUL
PEOPLE WHO DO THE IMPORTANT WORK
EVERY DAY OF ORGANIZING COST OF
VOLUNTEERS AND ENSURING THAT
THEY HAVE THE TRAINING, TOOLS
AND SUPPORT THEY NEED TO SERVE
AND SUCCEED IN THIS ESSENTIAL
ROLE. JOINING US ON THE SENATE
FLOOR TODAY ARE SHARON LAWRENCE
REAGAN PHILLIPS AND HER SON
CONNOR, CATHERINE MATTHEWS AND
ANDY JACOBSON. SHARON LAWRENCE
IS THE CEO OF CALIFORNIA CASA
AND A PASSIONATE ADVOCATE FOR
FOSTER YOUTH AND IMPROVING THE
FOSTER CARE SYSTEM. WITH A
BACKGROUND IN LAW AND PROVEN
SUCCESS. LEADING VOICES FOR
CHILDREN FOR OVER 20 YEARS,
SHARON BRINGS A WEALTH OF
EXPERIENCE AND A COMMITMENT TO
ADVOCATING FOR THE WELL-BEING OF
FOSTER CHILDREN ACROSS THE
STATE. REAGAN PHILLIPS, WHO IS
JOINED TODAY BY HER SON CONNOR
AS THE CEO OF CASA OF ORANGE
COUNTY. SHE BEGAN ADVOCATING FOR
CHILDREN IN FOSTER CARE,
STARTING WITH A CASA INTERNSHIP
IN NEW YORK AND CONTINUING
THROUGHOUT HER TIME IN LAW
SCHOOL. AFTER DOING WORK AS AN
ATTORNEY REPRESENTING CHILDREN
IN FOSTER CARE, SHE EXPANDED
THAT COMMITMENT BY JOINING THE
KOSOVO OC BOARD OF DIRECTORS,
BECOMING CASA CHIEF PROGRAM
OFFICER, AND ULTIMATELY
ASCENDING TO LEAD THE
ORGANIZATION AS ITS CHIEF
EXECUTIVE OFFICER. HER SON,
CONNOR, IS IN THIRD GRADE, WANTS
TO BE A BASEBALL PLAYER WHEN HE
GROWS UP. CATHERINE MATTHEWS HAS
BEEN THE CHIEF PROGRAM OFFICER
FOR CALIFORNIA CASA SINCE 2021.
SHE BEGAN VOLUNTEERING AS A CASA
IN 2001, AND LATER TRANSITIONED
FROM THE CORPORATE WORLD TO THE
NONPROFIT WORLD, JOINING CASA OF
PLACER COUNTY AS PROGRAM
DIRECTOR IN 2007. WITH NEARLY
TWO DECADES OF DEDICATION, SHE
HAS STREAMLINED OPERATIONS,
EXPANDED SERVICE, AND INTRODUCED
INNOVATIVE NEW TRAINING
APPROACHES. ANDY JACOBSON IS AN
IS AN ADVOCATE SUPERVISOR FOR
CASA OF ORANGE COUNTY. ANDY HAS
A MASTER OF SOCIAL WORK DEGREE
FROM UCLA AND HAS BEEN A CASE
SUPERVISOR SINCE 2005. ANDY HAS
DEDICATED HER PROFESSIONAL
CAREER TO EMPOWERING AND
SUPPORTING VULNERABLE CHILDREN
IN THE FOSTER CARE SYSTEM.
DURING MY TIME AS A CASA, ANDY
WAS ACTUALLY MY CASE SUPERVISOR
AND SHE CAN PERSONALLY ATTEST TO
THE FACT THAT MY WIFE WAS A MUCH
BETTER CASA THAN I WAS. PLEASE
JOIN ME IN CELEBRATING CASA
APPRECIATION DAY AND THANKING
OUR GUESTS FOR THEIR ESSENTIAL
WORK IN THE FOSTER YOUTH SYSTEM
BY GIVING SHARON, REAGAN,
CATHERINE, AND ANDY A WARM
CALIFORNIA SENATE WELCOME.
WELCOME CASA ASSOCIATION.
SENATOR NEWMAN WILL TAKE THAT
FIRST PHOTO WITH HIM AND HIS
SPECIAL GUEST. ONLY.
PERFECT MEMBERS, IF YOU WISH TO
PARTICIPATE IN THE GROUP PHOTO,
PLEASE HEAD TO THE BACK OF THE
FLOOR
.
ALL RIGHT, MEMBERS, WE'RE ADDING
A, AN ADDITIONAL PRESENTATION ON
SENATOR EGGMAN. YOU'RE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU, THANK
YOU, MADAM PRESIDENT, JUST
MEMBERS JUST UNDER PRIVILEGES OF
THE FLOOR, WHEN WE'RE IN APRIL,
WE KNOW WE ALL FEEL LIKE IT'S A
TIGHT MONTH. WE'RE OUT THERE IN
BATTLE, BUT JUST BECAUSE WE ARE
SEVEN STRONG VETERANS ON THIS
FLOOR, I GOT PINS FOR ALL THE
VETERANS TO BE A PART OF THE
VETERANS CAUCUS THAT SAY, UNITED
STATES MILITARY ON THEM, IN
ADDITION TO THE SENATE WITH RED,
WHITE AND BLUE. SO I HAVE A
PRESENTATION TO MAKE TO EACH AND
EVERY SENATOR WHO IS A VETERAN.
IF YOU SEE ME, WE CAN ALL WEAR
ONE TOGETHER, AND MAYBE JEFF
WILL TAKE A PICTURE OF US. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH AND THANK US ALL
FOR OUR SERVICE. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU, SENATOR. CONCLUDING
OUR PRESENTATIONS IS GOING TO BE
OUR PRO TEM. SIR. ARE YOU READY?
YES, MA'AM. THANK YOU. YOU MAY
PROCEED. THANK YOU, MADAM
PRESIDENT. WONDERFUL JOB TODAY.
GRATEFUL FOR YOUR WORK, MEMBERS,
I'LL BE QUICK, SENATOR DODD AND
I ARE HONORED TO BE ABLE TO WORK
ON BEHALF OF THE GREAT CITY OF
PETALUMA. EACH AND EVERY DAY.
TOGETHER, WE SPLIT THAT
RESPONSIBILITY. AND TODAY WE
HAVE SOME VERY SPECIAL GUESTS IN
THE HOUSE. IN FACT, WE HAVE
GAUCHOS IN THE HOUSE TODAY
JOINING US IN THE GALLERY. OUR
STUDENTS FROM THE ESTEEMED HIGH
SCHOOL, CASA GRANDE AND
PETALUMA, THEY'RE HERE WORKING
THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS AND
FOCUS ON THE IMPORTANCE OF CIVIC
ENGAGEMENT. IF WE CAN, PLEASE
GIVE A WARM CALIFORNIA SENATE
WELCOME TO THE CASA GRANDE
GAUCHOS. WELCOME TO OUR THE HIGH
SCHOOL STUDENTS. THANK YOU. NOW
WE'RE MOVING ON TO MESSAGES FROM
THE GOVERNOR WILL BE DEEMED
READ. MESSAGES FROM THE ASSEMBLY
WILL BE DEEMED READ. REPORTS OF
COMMITTEE WILL BE DEEMED READ,
AND AMENDMENTS ADOPTED UNDER
MOTIONS, RESOLUTIONS AND NOTICES
. WE HAVE NONE. MOVING ON TO
CONSIDERATION OF THE DAILY FILE.
STARTING OFF WITH THEIR SECOND
READING ITEMS, ONE THROUGH 20.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ SENATE
BILL 1361 1512 1264 WITH
AMENDMENTS 906, WITH AMENDMENTS
988, WITH AMENDMENTS 1066. WITH
AMENDMENTS 1143. WITH AMENDMENTS
1230. SECOND READING WILL BE
DEEMED READ. MOVING ON TO
SENATE. THIRD READING ITEM
NUMBER 44. SENATOR CORTEZ, ARE
YOU PREPARED? YES, MADAM
PRESIDENT. THANK YOU. ONE
SECOND. SENATOR. SECRETARY,
PLEASE READ SENATE RESOLUTION 86
BY SENATOR CORTEZ, RELATIVE TO
EDUCATION AND SHARING DAY
CALIFORNIA. SENATOR, YOU YOU MAY
PROCEED NOW. YEAH. THANK YOU
AGAIN, MADAM PRESIDENT AND
COLLEAGUES, SR 86 RECOGNIZES
TOMORROW, FRIDAY, APRIL 19TH, AS
EDUCATION AND SHARING DAY. THIS
RESOLUTION IS A TRIBUTE TO A
GREAT MAN WITH AN IMPORTANT
MESSAGE FOR US ALL. RABBI
MENACHEM MENDEL SCHNEERSON,
KNOWN AS RABBI, BECAME THE
LEADER OF CHABAD LUBAVITCH. THE
MOVEMENT IN 1950 WHEN HE
CONCENTRATED HIS EFFORTS ON
REBUILDING AND ENERGIZING THE
GLOBAL JEWISH COMMUNITY. AFTER
THE DEVASTATION OF THE
HOLOCAUST. HE PAID GREAT
ATTENTION TO THE NEEDS OF ALL
COMMUNITIES, OF ALL HUMANITY.
THE RABBI TRAINED HIS STUDENTS
TO MOVE OUT TO EVERY CORNER OF
THE GLOBE TO SET UP OUTPOSTS IN
EDUCATION, LIGHT AND LOVE TO
TODAY, CHABAD LUBAVITCH HAS
REPRESENTATIVES ON EVERY
CONTINENT, ON THE GLOBE, IN OUR
100 COUNTRIES, IN EVERY STATE,
IN OUR UNION, THE FIRST CHABAD
INSTITUTION IN CALIFORNIA WAS
ESTABLISHED IN 1965 AND IS
BOSTON. OVER 300 INSTITUTIONS IN
CALIFORNIA. THE RABBI TAUGHT
THAT EVERY INDIVIDUAL AND EVERY
INDIVIDUAL ACTION HAS AN IMPACT
ON THE ENTIRE UNIVERSE. HE
EMPHASIZED THE IMPORTANCE OF
EDUCATION AND GOOD CHARACTER,
AND INSTILLED THE HOPE FOR A
BRIGHTER FUTURE INTO THE LIVES
OF COUNTLESS PEOPLE IN AMERICA
AND ACROSS THE GLOBE. THE RABBI
TAUGHT THAT THE EDUCATION SHOULD
NOT BE LIMITED TO ACQUIRING
KNOWLEDGE AND PREPARATION FOR A
CAREER. HE PRIORITIZED BUILDING
CHARACTER WITH EMPHASIS ON MORAL
AND ETHICAL VALUES. OVER THE
LAST FOUR DECADES, THE US
CONGRESS AND PRESIDENTS HAVE
RECOGNIZED EDUCATION AND SHARING
DAY. IT IS RECOGNIZED ON THE
REBBE'S BIRTHDAY AND TRIBUTE TO
HIS COMMITMENT TO TEACHING
ETHICAL VALUES TO THE NEXT
GENERATION OF AMERICANS. THIS
DAY PROVIDES US THE OPPORTUNITY
TO PAUSE AND RECOGNIZE OUR
RESPONSIBILITY TO ENSURE THAT
OUR YOUNG PEOPLE HAVE THE
FOUNDATION NECESSARY TO LEAD
LIVES RICH IN PURPOSE AND
FULFILLMENT. THE RABBI TAUGHT
THAT IN TRUTH, EVERY PERSON IS
AN EDUCATOR AND WE MUST BE
MINDFUL OF OUR ABILITY TO IMPACT
THE LIVES OF OTHERS. PEOPLE ARE
MORE INFLUENCED BY THE THINGS
THEY DO THAN BY THE KNOWLEDGE
THEY ARE TAUGHT. THEREFORE,
BEYOND THE CONVERSATIONS, IT'S
IMPORTANT TO PROMOTE THESE IDEAS
THROUGH ACTION. THIS RESOLUTION
CALLS UPON CALIFORNIANS TO
REFLECT ON OUR COLLECTIVE
OBLIGATION TO ENHANCE THE TRUE
EDUCATION OF OUR CHILDREN, TO
SERVE AS PROPER ROLE MODELS, AND
TO TAKE CONCRETE ACTION TO BRING
MORE GOODNESS AND KINDNESS INTO
OUR WORLD. THANK YOU. AND I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR
SUPPORT ON THIS RESOLUTION.
SENATOR STERN, YOU'RE RECOGNIZED
. THANK YOU. JUST TO BRIEFLY ADD
MY GRATITUDE, NOT JUST FOR THE
SENATOR FOR SAN JOSE, BUT, THE
INDIRECT EFFECT HERE IS NOW MY
DAUGHTER GETS TO GO TO PRESCHOOL
, AND A DIVERSE GROUP OF KIDS,
IN THE SAN FERNANDO VALLEY ARE
LEARNING THESE VALUES, STARTING
FROM FROM FROM SQUARE ONE. BUT
IT'S TRUE. ANYWHERE IN THE
WORLD, WHEN YOU SHOW UP, THERE'S
A THERE'S AN OPEN MINDSET. AND
IN, ESPECIALLY WITHIN THE JEWISH
FAITH, SOMETIMES WE CAN GET
CLOSED AND, JUDGMENTAL AND
SECTARIAN. AND WHAT THIS IS, IS
AN OPENNESS THAT EXTENDS BEYOND
EVEN THIS FAITH TO ALL FAITHS.
SO AND THOSE WHO DON'T EVEN HAVE
A FAITH IN SEEKING ONE ANYWAY,
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
DO YOU HAVE ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON FILE
ITEM 44? SEEING NONE, SENATOR
CORTEZ, YOU MAY CLOSE. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE MEMBERS. THIS ITEM IS
ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS ROLLCALL.
ANY OBJECTION TO UTILIZING THE
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL? AYES 39. NO
ZERO RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED. AND
NOW MOVING FORWARD TOWARDS
CONSENT. CALENDAR ITEMS 68
THROUGH 74. IS THERE ANY MEMBER
THAT WOULD LIKE TO REMOVE AN
ITEM FROM THE CONSENT CALENDAR?
SEEING NONE. SECRETARY, PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL ON THE FIRST ITEM.
PLEASE READ. PLEASE READ.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ THE FIRST
ITEM. SENATE BILL 1479 8510 27
1183 1186 1412 1428 586 1366
1063. ASSEMBLY. CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION 148 ONE 5156 160.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
IN THE FIRST ITEM. ALAN AYE.
ALVARADO. GIL AYE. ARCHULETA
AYE. ASHBY. AYE. ATKINS AYE.
BECKER AYE. BLAKESBERG. AYE.
BRADFORD AYE. CABALLERO. AYE.
CORTEZ AYE. DALLI. AYE. DODD
AYE. DURAZZO. AYE. EGGMAN AYE.
GLAZER. AYE. GONZALEZ AYE. GROVE
AYE OR DATO JONES AYE. LAIRD
AYE. LIMÓN AYE. MCGUIRE MENJIVAR
I MEAN AYE. NEWMAN AYE. NGUYEN.
AYE. NILO AYE. OKOBO. AYE. PADIM
AYE. PORTANTINO. AYE. ROTH AYE.
RUBIO. AYE. SATO AYE. SKINNER.
AYE. SMALLWOOD CUEVAS. AYE.
STERN. AYE UMBERG. AYE. WAHAB
AYE. WIENER. AYE. WILK. AYE
SECRETARY. PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. HURTADO. MCGUIRE
AYE. AYES 39. NO ZERO. CONSENT
CALENDAR IS APPROVED. NOW ON TO
SPECIAL CONSENT CALENDAR. ITEM
75 THROUGH 81. WE DID THAT
ALREADY. SO MOVING RETURNING TO
MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS. NOW IS
OUR TIME FOR ADJOURN IN
MEMORIES. SENATOR BRADFORD, ARE
YOU PREPARED? SENATORS, AS
NICELY AS POSSIBLE. COULD WE
RETURN TO OUR DESKS OR TAKE OUR
CONVERSATIONS OFF THE FLOOR?
THANK YOU, MADAM PRESIDENT. I
STAND HERE TODAY ASKING YOU TO
JOIN IN THE ADJOURNMENT OF AN
AMAZING HUMAN BEING. MR. ELON
SAMUEL GUNNING, WHO PASSED AWAY
ON OCTOBER 7TH, 2023, 2023, AT
THE TENDER AGE OF 99. HE WAS A
LOVING SON, HUSBAND, FATHER,
GRANDFATHER AND FRIEND TO MANY.
MR. GUNNING WAS BORN ON JANUARY
27TH, 1924, IN JAMAICA. HE WAS A
SON OF HUMBLE BUT PROUD PARENTS,
NORMAN AND MARY GUNNING. HIS
FATHER PASSED AWAY WHEN MR.
GUNNING WAS ONLY NINE YEARS OLD,
AND THROUGH FINANCIAL STRUGGLES
AND HARD WORK, WAS ABLE TO EARN
A CIVIL ENGINEERING DEGREE
BEFORE HE EMIGRATED TO NEW YORK
IN 1952, HE WAS THE ASSISTANT
CITY ENGINEER FOR THE CITY OF
MONTEGO BAY AND JAMAICA. HE
SPENT THREE AND A HALF YEARS IN
NEW YORK AS PART OF A LARGE
CONSULTING ENGINEERING FIRM, AND
HELPED SUPERVISE THE
CONSTRUCTION OF TWO MAJOR
HIGHWAYS IN NEW YORK CITY. IN
1956, MR. GUNNING VISITED THE
CITY OF LOS ANGELES FOR THE
FIRST TIME, AND FELL IN LOVE
WITH IT. BEFORE HIS VACATION WAS
OVER, HE HAD LANDED A JOB WITH
AN ENGINEERING FIRM OF DANIEL
MANN JOHNSON AND MENDENHALL. HE
BROUGHT HIS FAMILY, INCLUDING
HIS TWO SONS, MICHAEL AND MARK,
TO CALIFORNIA LATER THAT YEAR.
YES, THAT MICHAEL GUNNING. HE
LEFT TO LEAVE THE ENGINEERING
FIELD AND THE EARLY 70S TO
INVEST IN REAL ESTATE, WHICH WAS
ALWAYS BEEN A FIELD THAT HE
ENJOYED, AND HE WAS VERY
SUCCESSFUL AT IT. MR. GUNNING
AND HIS FAMILY WERE MEMBERS OF
THE WILSHIRE METHODIST CHURCH,
STARTING IN 1962, AND HE NOTICED
THAT THE CHOIR WAS ALL WHITE. SO
HE STARTED A PROCESS FOR
INTEGRATING IT. HE WENT ON TO
HOLD SEVERAL LEADERSHIP
POSITIONS WITH THE CHURCH, AND
WAS A MEMBER OF THE BOARD OF
TRUSTEES UNTIL HIS VERY LAST
DAY. HE ALSO HAD A GREAT PASSION
FOR GOLF, AND THAT'S WHERE I MET
MR. GUNNING FOR THE FIRST TIME
ON A GOLF COURSE AND FOR 20
YEARS HE ARRANGED TRIPS TO
JAMAICA AND LOVED ACTING AS AN
OFFICIAL TOUR GUIDE. IN HIS
HOMELAND. FOR ANYONE WHO WANTED
TO VISIT MR. GUNNING APPROACHED
GOLF IN THE SAME WAY HE DID WITH
HIS LIFE WITH PASSION, WITH
HONESTY AND INTEGRITY. HE IS
SURVIVED BY HIS WIFE, JEAN, HIS
SONS MICHAEL AND MARK, FOUR
GRANDCHILDREN AND NUMEROUS
RELATIVES AND FRIENDS. AND I
CONSIDER MYSELF ONE OF THOSE
FRIENDS. HE'LL BE FOREVER
REMEMBERED FOR HIS ICONIC,
ICONIC GREETING OF HEY BUDDY,
WHAT A SMILE AND A WARM
HANDSHAKE! PLEASE JOIN ME IN
ADJOURNING IN THE MEMORY OF
ELLEN SAMUEL GUNNING. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU, SENATOR, FOR SHARING
HIS STORY WITH US. PLEASE BRING
HIS NAME FORWARD SO THAT HE MAY
BE PROPERLY MEMORIALIZED IN THE
JOURNAL. SENATOR. MEN, ARE YOU
PREPARED? YES. PLEASE PROCEED,
THANK YOU, MADAM PRESIDENT AND
MEMBERS. I RISE TO ADJOURN IN
MEMORY OF ORANGE COUNTY FIRE
AUTHORITY. CAPTAIN AND PARAMEDIC
ROBIN CULP. ROB DEDICATED HIS
LIFE TO SERVING OTHERS THROUGH
HIS WORK IN THE FIRE SERVICE.
AND FOR 25 YEARS, HE SELFLESSLY
ANSWERED THE CALL OF DUTY,
EARNING THE RESPECT AND
ADMIRATION OF ALL THOSE HE
WORKED WITH. ROB WAS BORN ON
FEBRUARY 26TH, 1971 AND GREW UP
IN LAGUNA BEACH. FOLLOWING A
SERIES OF FIRES IN 1993, ROB
WENT OUT AND HELPED HIS FRIENDS
AND LOVED ONES SAVE THE
MEMORABILIA AND CHERISHED ITEMS
FROM THEIR HOMES, AND THIS
SPARKED HIS EVENTUAL INTEREST IN
FIREFIGHTING. HE JOINED THE
NATIONAL CITY FIRE DEPARTMENT A
FEW YEARS LATER IN 1999, THEN
MOVED OVER TO THE CARLSBAD FIRE
DEPARTMENT IN 2003 BEFORE COMING
BACK HOME TO WORK FOR THE ORANGE
COUNTY FIRE AUTHORITY IN 2007.
IN ADDITION TO BEING A
FIREFIGHTER AND PARAMEDIC, ROB
PLAYED A CRUCIAL ROLE IN
EMERGENCY RESPONSE AND DISASTER
RELIEF EFFORTS, SERVING AS A
MEMBER OF THE TECHNICAL RESCUE
TEAM AND AS PART OF FEMA'S URBAN
SEARCH AND RESCUE CALIFORNIA
TASK FORCE FIVE. HE WAS A
DEDICATED FATHER AND HUSBAND WHO
LOVED THE OUTDOORS. A TRUE
LAGUNA BEACH NATIVE, HE LOVED TO
SURF, SNOWBOARD, AND MOUNTAIN
BIKE IN HIS SPARE TIME. HIS
UNWAVERING COMMITMENT TO PUBLIC
SAFETY THROUGHOUT HIS LIFE
TOUCHED THE LIVES OF COUNTLESS
INDIVIDUALS, INCLUDING MY OWN
FAMILY. WHILE I NEVER HAD THE
CHANCE TO MEET ROB PERSONALLY,
HE DID COME INTO MY LIFE AS WE
HAD A SCARY INCIDENT IN MY HOME
A COUPLE OF YEARS BACK. WHILE I
WAS UP HERE IN SACRAMENTO. HE
WAS THE CAPTAIN OF THE FIRST
RESPONDERS WHO CAME TO MY HOME
IN IRVINE AND HE HELPED CALM AND
SOOTHE THE FEARS OF MY WIFE, WHO
DESCRIBED IT AS THE SCARIEST
INCIDENT SHE'D EVER SEEN WITH
ONE OF OUR KIDS, TALKED HER
THROUGH THE FEARS AS SHE HAD AS
THEY WENT TO THE HOSPITAL IN THE
BACK OF THE AMBULANCE AND JUST
AS A POSTSCRIPT, EVERYTHING
TURNED OUT TO BE JUST FINE. BUT
HIS CALM PRESENCE WAS SOMETHING
THAT CALM AND STABLE PRESENCE
AND DEEP KINDNESS WERE THE WORDS
THAT MY WIFE USED TO DESCRIBE
HIM. FROM THAT EXPERIENCE, HIS
FELLOW FIREFIGHTERS DESCRIBE HIM
AS THE GUY THAT ALWAYS CAME TO
WORK WITH A SMILE ON HIS FACE.
NO MATTER THE ADVERSITIES HE
FACED. HE WAS HAPPY, ALWAYS
ACTIVE AND HEALTHY. HE WAS A
PROUD FATHER TO HIS TWO
CHILDREN. ROBIN PASSED AWAY
SURROUNDED BY HIS FAMILY ON
MARCH 4TH, 2023. WAY TOO SOON.
BUT HIS LEGACY WILL LIVE ON
THROUGH HIS FAMILY, INCLUDING
HIS WIFE KATIE HANGUM CULP AND
HIS CHILDREN JAXON AND MADISON.
AS WELL AS HIS COLLEAGUES AND
ALL OF THE MANY, MANY PEOPLE
WHOSE LIVES HE POSITIVELY
AFFECTED. I ASK THAT WE ADJOURN
IN HIS MEMORY TODAY. THANK YOU,
SENATOR BLAKESBERG. YOU'RE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU, SENATOR
MINH, FOR THAT TRIBUTE AND THE
PERSONAL CONNECTION THAT YOU
HAVE TO HIM AND YOUR FAMILY
DOES. I ALSO RISE TODAY TO PAY
TRIBUTE TO FIRE CAPTAIN ROB
CULP. HIS LEGACY AND REPUTATION
MAKE MY CONSTITUENCY AND
CONSTITUENTS AND ME VERY PROUD.
CAPTAIN CULP WAS MADE A
SIGNIFICANT POSITIVE IMPACT IN
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA, AND WE ARE
DEEPLY SADDENED FOR HIS PASSING.
I'M GRATEFUL FOR HIS DEDICATED
SERVICE TO THE NATIONAL CITY
FIRE DEPARTMENT, THE CARLSBAD
FIRE DEPARTMENT AND THE ORANGE
COUNTY FIRE AUTHORITY OVER THE
PAST 25 YEARS. HE LEAVES BEHIND
A LASTING LEGACY OF COURAGE,
COMMITMENT AND CARE IN THE
COMMUNITIES HE SERVED DURING HIS
16 YEARS WITH THE ORANGE COUNTY
FIRE AUTHORITY. CULP SERVED AS
FIREFIGHTER, PARAMEDIC, FIRE
APPARATUS ENGINEER, FIRE
CAPTAIN, PARAMEDIC AND WAS A
MEMBER OF THE TECHNICAL RESCUE
TEAM AND THE FEMA CALIFORNIA
TASK FORCE FIVE. HE WAS A TRUE
PUBLIC SERVANT AND WE ARE
FOREVER GRATEFUL WITH THAT.
THANK YOU FOR HONORING CAPTAIN
CULP, SENATOR MINH, AND TOGETHER
WE ASK THAT THE SENATE ADJOURN
IN HIS MEMORY. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. SENATOR, PLEASE BRING THAT
FIRE HERO'S NAME FORWARD SO THAT
HE MAY BE PROPERLY MEMORIALIZED
IN THE JOURNAL. SENATOR
PORTANTINO, ARE YOU PREPARED?
MEMBERS, I RISE TODAY TO ASK US
TO ADJOURN IN MEMORY OF ROSETTA
LEE MORRIS, A DISTINGUISHED
CALIFORNIAN WHOSE CHARACTER AND
DEEDS IN LIFE MERIT, GRATITUDE
AND RESPECT ACKNOWLEDGE BY THE
PEOPLE OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. ROSETTA LEE MORRIS
WAS BORN AUGUST 17TH, 1948, IN
TULSA, OKLAHOMA, AND RAISED BY
PARENTS JOHNNY CLAUSEN SENIOR
AND ROSE MARIE SEALS. ROSE
MORRIS ATTENDED BOOKER T
WASHINGTON HIGH SCHOOL AND
GRADUATED IN 1966. HAVING
EXCELLED IN HER STUDIES WHILE
DEVELOPING A LOVE FOR MUSIC AND
SINGING WITH A LOCAL ALL FEMALE
GROUP KNOWN AS THE DYNAMICS. IN
1967, SHE MET RAYMOND LEE MORRIS
IN OKLAHOMA CITY, AND THEY
SUBSEQUENTLY MARRIED IN 1968.
TOGETHER, THEY RAISED THEIR
CHILDREN, MICHELLE AND MICHAEL.
IN 1975, ROSE AND HER FAMILY
MOVED TO CALIFORNIA, WHERE SHE
SECURED EMPLOYMENT WITH THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE AND
CONTRIBUTED TO A NUMBER OF
LEGISLATIVE COMMITTEES. DURING
THE COURSE OF HER STELLAR 35
YEAR STATE SERVICE CAREER,
INCLUDING THE ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE
ON HAZARDOUS WASTE AND TOXIC
MATERIALS, THE ASSEMBLY
COMMITTEE ON PUBLIC SAFETY, THE
SENATE COMMITTEE ON NATURAL
WILDFIRE WILDLIFE. THE SENATE
COMMITTEE ON REVENUE AND
TAXATION, AND THE SENATE BUDGET
AND FISCAL REVIEW SUBCOMMITTEE
UNTIL Ã RETIREMENT IN 2010.
ROSE HAD A PASSION FOR NATURE
AND BEAUTY. SHE CULTIVATED
FLOWERS IN HER GARDEN AND WAS A
COLLECTOR OF MANY BOOKS. THE
HIGH ESTEEM IN WHICH SHE WAS
HELD BY HER LOVING FAMILY, HER
NUMEROUS FRIENDS AND OTHER
INDIVIDUALS FORTUNATE ENOUGH TO
HAVE KNOWN HER, STANDS AS A
TESTAMENT FOR OTHERS WHO STRIVE
FOR THE BEST IN EVERY ASPECT OF
THEIR LIVES. ROSETTA LEE MORRIS
IS SURVIVED BY HER DAUGHTER,
MICHELLE MORRIS BATTLE, A FORMER
SENATE EMPLOYEE. HER
GRANDCHILDREN, ALEXANDER MIGUEL
RIVERA MORRIS, DANTE TERRELL
MORRIS, MICHAEL JAVON CALHOUN,
LEE ANTHONY WARD, TAHJ TERRELL
MORRIS, MICAH LEÓN MORRIS,
ANTHONY LEE BATTLE, MALIA,
MICHELLE WARD. HER GREAT
GRANDCHILDREN JOVI, RIVERA,
JAMISON RIVERA, JOSIAH CALHOUN,
AND MICAH CALHOUN AND HER SEVEN
SIBLINGS. THIS IS A TRULY
EXTENDED, LARGE, WONDERFUL
FAMILY. I EXPRESS MY DEEPEST
SYMPATHY AT THE PASSING OF
ROSETTA LEE MORRIS AND BY THIS
RESOLUTION, OBVIOUSLY
MEMORIALIZE HER FOR HER
ILLUSTRIOUS SERVICE TO OUR STATE
AND IN PARTICULAR THE
LEGISLATURE. AND RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR US TO ADJOURN IN HER
MEMORY. THANK YOU. SENATOR,
PLEASE BRING HER NAME FORWARD SO
THAT SHE MAY BE MEMORIALIZED IN
THE JOURNAL. MOVING ON TO
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS. ANY
COMMITTEE COMMITTEE
ANNOUNCEMENTS. THOSE AREN'T DONE
HERE. SENATOR LAIRD, YOU'RE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU VERY MUCH,
MADAM PRESIDENT, BUDGET
SUBCOMMITTEE ONE ON EDUCATION
WILL MEET IN THE SWING SPACE
ROOM 2100, UPON ADJOURNMENT.
SENATOR BECKER, YOU'RE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU, MADAM
PRESIDENT. BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE
NUMBER TWO ON ENERGY, NATURAL
RESOURCES AND THE ENVIRONMENT
WILL MEET IN ROOM 2200IN THE
SWING SPACE, 15 MINUTES AFTER
END OF SESSION. BUDGET
SUBCOMMITTEE NUMBER THREE ON
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES WILL
MEET IN ROOM 1200 15 MINUTES
AFTER SESSION. SENATOR PADILLA,
YOU'RE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU,
MADAM PRESIDENT. BUDGET
SUBCOMMITTEE NUMBER FOUR ON
STATE ADMINISTRATION AND
GOVERNMENT WILL CONVENE UPON
ADJOURNMENT IN ROOM 113 HERE IN
THE CAPITOL. SENATOR. ROB,
YOU'RE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU.
SUB BUDGET SUB NUMBER FIVE WILL
MEET IN ROOM 112 IMMEDIATELY
AFTER SESSION. THANK YOU. BEFORE
WE GO TO MR. PRO TEM, WE'RE
GOING TO RECOGNIZE TWO SPECIAL
THINGS. FIRST, WE'VE GOT TO
RECOGNIZE SENATOR CABALLERO. HER
BIRTHDAY, IF I'M NOT MISTAKEN,
IS TOMORROW. AND THEN ALSO. SO
WE NEED TO RECOGNIZE ME BECAUSE
MY BIRTHDAY IS THIS SUNDAY. I
DID ALREADY. IF THERE IS NO
OTHER BUSINESS, MR. PRO TEM, THE
DESK IS CLEAR. MADAM PRESIDENT,
THANK YOU SO MUCH. HAVE A
BIRTHDAY, BY THE WAY, TO MADAM
PRESIDENT. OF COURSE. SENATOR
CABALLERO. AND YOU JUST
WITNESSED EACH OF THE BUDGET SUB
CHAIRS STANDING, THERE IS A
MAJORITY OF THIS BODY WHO SERVES
ON THE BUDGET COMMITTEE, AND WE
OWE THEM A DEBT OF GRATITUDE,
ESPECIALLY THIS YEAR WITH THE
CHALLENGES THAT WE FACE WORKING
TOGETHER TO BE ABLE TO GET THE
JOB DONE. AND I WANT TO SAY
THANK YOU TO OUR BUDGET SUB
CHAIRS AND TO EACH OF THE
MEMBERS OF OUR BUDGET COMMITTEE
ON BOTH SIDES OF THE AISLE.
WE'RE GRATEFUL FOR YOUR WORK,
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN. THE NEXT
FLOOR SESSION IS SCHEDULED FOR
MONDAY, APRIL 22ND AT NINE AT 2
P.M. 2 P.M. ENJOY THE WEEKEND.
THE SENATE WILL BE IN RECESS
UNTIL 3:30 P.M, AT WHICH TIME
THE ADJOURNMENT MOTION WILL BE
MADE. WE WILL RECONVENE MONDAY
AT 2 P.M.